[Musique]
une ambiance festive que tous les
réunionnais connaissent bien transporter
le temps d'une journée dans les centres
d'hébergement dherin le bénéficiaire du
dispositif d'accompagnement des malades
du département de la réunion
au menu 500 kg de l'eau tikkari rougail
samoussas de quoi ravir les papilles et
réchauffé les coeurs et famille d'un
malade réunion le fait de retrouver un
compatriote
c'est un rassemblement comme ça mais
moi la réunion du paillon du ballon
leur montrer qu'on ne les oublie pas
c'est aussi la motivation des artistes
présents pour l'événement des malades
sont là il vous arrive pouvait être
soigné il était voilà mais ils sont là
maintenant exposé à peut-être soleil
mais moi cela prenne un peu de soleil
pouvoir se passe dans des champs j'ai un
petit peu satisfait pas déplacé et
satisfait déplacés vivent un petit
chance on essaye fait plaisir ali après
ma pote de bonnes chansons si en même
temps apporte un peu de la joie de la
bonne humeur en cette fin d'année
pourtant on en retrouve un type solaire
on trouve un petit peu l'ambiance la
réunion et puis 711 est aussi un petit
peu que ce n'est pas à terre que menad
money suivent azote et si c'est un façon
de donner à ton petit peu plus beaux
mots cap au bac exact maladie
mais ferrer ca me ferais ça tous les
jours beaucoup de ces familles sont dans
l'hexagone depuis plusieurs mois voire
des années pour ce noël solidaire des
élus du département ont tenu à être
présent pour les rencontrer
[Musique]
rabat maroc
la vie beaucoup est une fierté pour moi
de participer à cet événement basé sur
une console identité pour montrer à nos
compatriotes de réunionnais bien qu'on
est solidaire avec eux et qu'on pense à
eux vous savez c'est pas évident dans un
premier temps découvrir qu'on a une
maladie grave et après dans un deuxième
temps savoir qu'on va devoir se faire
soigner à treize mille kilomètres donc
il était important pour nous de faire
jouer cette solidarité là et de venir
ici à leur rencontre doit leur apporter
un peu de soleil un peu de baume au
coeur et montrer notre solidarité aux
docks et les messages que me veux faire
passer à tous ses compatriotes à tous
ces personnes malades et à cette famille
c'est que tant dans la vie rina l'espoir
baisse pas les bras nous élus à réunion
ne sera toujours là pour accompagner zot
pour être à l'autre côté et surtout
notre mission aussi aujourd'hui c'est
surtout d'améliorer le dispositif est en
7 décembre pour nous à la réunion c'est
les flamboyants l'ambiance la fed le
leti et bien c'est ce que nous voulions
ramener parce que ben voilà nous prend
sa date et nous souhaite à z un bon
rétablissement surtout na des personnes
que les là depuis quatre ans les normes
depuis quatre ans et donc voilà nous ce
que nous l'a voulu ayant profité pour
remercier notre président monsieur
melchior remercier toutes les personnes
qu'elle a participé à ce bel événement
n'a pas pu faire comme nous voulaient
parce qu'il fallait adapter à la crise
sanitaire mais franchement l'événement
les belles et nous passent aussi un bon
moment
[Musique]
un
plaisir partagé pour tous est une
occasion pour les élus de rencontrer les
acteurs mobilisés au quotidien autour du
dispositif c'était totalement
indispensable pour eux le quotidien
parisien et surtout en hiver et pas le
plus joyeux et c'est un peu de soleil
pas clairement pour jeanne hoareau
conseillère départementale
c'est aussi l'occasion de retrouvailles
et maintenant les
besoins de contacter des gens c'est une
force pour nous parce qu'il permet à
nous quand même de parler et me dit
souvent la parole libère il guérit pas
non mais paix mais à nous de prendre
conscience que nous lé pas les seuls à
avoir cette situation hélas aujourd'hui
mon grand bonheur c'est de voir jeanne
j'en sais c'est une amie avec laquelle
nous l'avons dit encore pendant un bout
de temps religieusement nous était très
impliqué est là aujourd'hui c'est
c'est la rencontre en tant qu'élu je
vois les choses différemment c'est de
jouer là on n'a pas couru on n'a pas
couru vers les hôpitaux via les malades
tout ça mais c'est
je vois ça donne d'une autre façon
maintenant moi ce que j'aime ici c'est
cette solidarité
à la réunion on en a mais là devant
cette situation on est plus soudé c'est
ça qui est beau
depuis plus d'un an marlène et son fils
stéphane sont accompagnés par le
département à cause de son état de santé
encore fragile stéphane n'a pas pu
participer à ce déjeuner alors la
réunion est venue la nuit
on
va vous la saison tourteaux
[Musique]
sera différent l'année passée avait
passé matter gay pas moi je rie out
total là cet avis mais ce plaisir moi
passer noël chez à wichita
comment les d'aia stéphane donc la ville
cinq ans a fondé son araignée pour sa
part ici que mon ballon chanter
et téléphone et je me marre oui c'est
beaucoup d'émotions moins bon temps le
franchement d'une réunion entre les
yonnais
plein jouable est franchement une plein
d'émotions positives données l'énergie
que l'hépatite et comment voter une
réunion est savamment passe le cap de
noël doit même que leurs amis les loin
le dl et là on penser ça le dl et là le
dr denis
il faisait bon il que des frais
non elle avait la rosée dans le ciel à
tori jean t il marcher
d'abord des il peut dire on
[Musique]
a
visé dans le ciel
chanter
dieter
[Musique]
franchement ému là parce que
la traque à celle des provençaux qu'on
fait de loin mais voilà ma boîte
contenterait messi mais j'ai retrouvé
ma musique cette année 150 familles ont
bénéficié du dispositif d'accompagnement
des malades un travail d' équipes du
pôle social de l'open de paris et des
agents sur google
docs et si je pense qu'il n'ya pas tous
les voit danser chanter
participer eux-mêmes qui joue rescue me
connaissent je dois d'ailleurs c'est
magnifique mais il faut aussi voir qu'il
ya des agents la réunion moi j'aimerais
quand même qu'on les reconnaissances
pour ces agents également donc le fait
de faire les manifestations de temps en
temps pour montrer que le département
est là et que voilà ils peuvent compter
sur nous c'est quand même important des
réunionnais requinqué par cet élan de
solidarité
une opération réussie pour le
département de l'ariège
[Musique]